merci ça fait plaisir vraiment
chaleureusement accueilli par une sale
comble entourée de ténors de l'UMP et du
centre Marie-Louise Fort voulait marquer
les esprits pour son retour sur la scène
municipale rapidement elle annonce ce
qui n'était plus qu'un secret largement
éventé oui je suis candidate à la mairie
de sens
une décision longuement réfléchie la
députée se lance dans la bataille
municipale par conviction mais aussi par
deux voir elle se pose un peu en recours
pour l'UMP à sens il y a une part de
cœur je l'ai dit tout à l'heure il y a
une part de raison et c'est vrai que la
situation de la ville est très
inquiétante et je dois dire que depuis
plusieurs mois et oui un peu plus même
les mers des communes s'inquiète de la
situation de la ville centre et c'est
vrai que les enjeux tournent quand même
autour de la ville qui a énormément
stagné et qui manque de gouvernance tout
simplement face à une situation plus que
confuse à Sens Marie-Louise Fort veut
incarner la stabilité et l'expérience sa
notoriété face à des candidats souvent
peu connus du grand public jouent
également sa faveur elle était déjà mère
après les communistes j'espère qu'elle
va maintenant être mère après
l'équipe qui est en ce moment il y a
plus rien de toute façon il y a pas de
dirigeants ça dit ça se dirige pas c'est
le problème principal de sens
qui depuis les années 71 comme l'a
rappelé Henri Dorincourt pratique le
zapping municipal il faudra pour sens
au moins un mandat si ce n'est deux pour
arriver à ramener une stabilité sur la
ville la sécurité sera l'un de ses axes
forts de campagne une façon de labourer
sur les terres du FN d'Edouard Ferrand
face à une gauche déchirée l'unité
affichée de la droite et du centre peut
également rassurer un petit grain de
sable toutefois dans cette union qui ne
sera pas totale l'udaïque Claude Vivier
est bien décidé à conduire une liste
centriste